hey with summer vacations approaching
everybody it's time to take a trip to
legoland
we have a behind the scenes look at a
newly at the newly revamped amusement
park in southern california check it out
we are so excited because legoland
california resort
is back open and just in time we have
both jay gonzalez and julie estrada to
give us the first look
inside their new attractions now julie
let's start with you you just opened
after a year of closure
and now you have a whole new land
talk about the lego movie land this is
exciting
i am standing here in bricksburg in the
middle of the lego movie
world where we are taking six new
interactive attractions
and from the lego movie and the lego
movie two inspired from both of those
putting our guests right here in the
middle of it all in the middle of the
lego movie universe
we have six different uh attractions
everything from cloud cuckoo land crepes
to unikitty's disco drop where you
get on board you fly high above cloud
cuckoo land
drop down spin around go back up again
and bounce your way back down to earth
all depending on unikitty's mood she's
kind of a fickle feline so
one of the greatest parts of watching
the ride is even when you're not on the
ride is watching the ride because you
can see
unikitty's face change she kind of gets
a little queasy when she gets
a little upset and then she gets giddy
and excited when the ride is thrilling
and the best for her i just i want to
sing
everything is awesome because that looks
absolutely
incredible i how can you not be happy
walking around there i jake can you give
us a little sneak peek from inside the
ride and
and tell us what guests can expect yes
and just like you everything is awesome
and guests can expect
the thrill of a lifetime i'm here in the
puppy palace where
emmett's flying adventure is and it's
our newest attraction to add to our
more than 60 ride shows and attractions
here at legoland california resort
let's go inside and actually see where
the flight takes off
for guests to enjoy so guests will be
able to go on emmett's
triple decker flying couch and zoom
through all the iconic lands from both
blockbuster films
um they will be able to have the nice
sweet smell from cloud cuckoo land
they'll zoom through middle z land
they'll actually get feel the ocean
spray and pirates cove
and blast off in the sistar system so as
you're racing against emmett's friends
now i can't tell you who wins the race
but i can
invite you out for an awesome experience
it's been a while since i've been to
legoland and we had an amazing
experience when we went the first time
now you guys have upped the annie i mean
this is
absolutely incredible now what are some
tips if
that you can share with families who
like us
are planning our trip to legoland what
what tips do you have for us
well there are many ways to maximize
your experience when you're planning a
trip to legoland california resort
first and foremost go online go to
legoland.com
book your tickets and get your
reservations ahead of time
all guests coming into the park need to
have a reserved date and
then download the legoland app the app
is so essential because it'll help you
really get the most out of your
experience when you're here you can look
up the height requirements for the rides
you can see the wait times for the rides
and you can even order food at some of
the different eateries throughout the
resort ahead of time or while you're
waiting in line for a ride
and then if you stay at legoland hotel
or legoland castle hotel
you have early access into the theme
park and you can get
great savings on bundle packages like
with sea life aquarium or with the water
park
thank you so much mercedes all right
last week